typically the first few days of class
these guys ask you know what's the class
average gonna be how are we gonna be
graded I don't have any answers for that
stuff so I say what is totally true that
I don't feel my main job is to grade
them my job is to teach them or learn
with them that's what I continue to do
and gradually they begin to believe
today on the podcast we're talking with
teaching legend professor Gil Strang
maybe the key point is to make it human
you know you're you're you're a person
like the student is a person the book
isn't quite a person but it was written
by a person welcome to talk radio a
podcast about inspired teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare one of o cw's most
popular courses is Professor Strang's
18:06 linear algebra a key foundation
for his new course on machine learning
in which he's teaching students to teach
computers professor Strang is known for
inspiring students through his teaching
one YouTube commenter sums it up well
quote this is not lecture this is art we
wanted to talk with professor Strang to
see how he's been able to make complex
math concepts engaging and accessible
we'll pick up our conversation with his
explanation of what is new course 1806
five matrix methods and data analysis
signal processing and machine learning
is all about so this is my adventure
into a subject of deep learning for
example recognizing an image recognizing
a zip code a bunch of numbers
translating languages or playing chess
so that's what the course is about how
does the machine learn
essentially the idea is they take an
image then the deep learning system
leads the machine to look at examples we
all learn from examples the machine
learns from these inputs and buy from
for many examples or many chess games of
many pages of Chinese you learn what's
happening and and what the the math part
is is that the machine ultimately tries
to assign a certain weight to a certain
number big or small to each part of the
image so perhaps if you're drawing a
three the image the computer recognizes
a three of course by the curves and and
gives less weight or zero weight
sometimes to the empty space around the
three but picks out that three so that's
the idea of deep learning
traditionally math courses have been
defined by testing which honestly makes
sense there's typically a right and a
wrong answer in math if you know the
operation if you do it right you should
get the answer tests can be a great
vehicle for strengthening and measuring
students skills but professor Strang's
approach is different so I ask everybody
to do a project there is no final exam
actually there's no exam at all I
shouldn't like to say this but that's
really what the subject is is having an
idea of how okay I'll use deep learning
for some things like the recent proposed
project was can you identify what makes
up an image or a picture attractive hmm
so somebody has to say you know these
pictures are attractive these are not we
have to tell the computer or something
what did that feel like to try something
new pedagogically oh it's fun you know I
I like teaching and this is a subject
where students just come from everywhere
because they know what stuff to learn
and they've heard about it and they
some of them know more than me but and
then they those students write even
better projects yeah it's just so I do
the lectures for the first three
quarters of the course and then I try to
get them to present which is a great
experience for them so it takes a little
purging to get them but yeah yeah it's
really just wonderful what insights have
you gained about having more of a
student-led course in a project-based
course any anything that you realize
slowly but finally that that's how
people learn by doing there that you
couldn't give them a better way to learn
than then create a project it usually
it's on some topic they know about or
they they're interested in like how do
you find a criminal and a bunch of
people yeah it's just it's a very
effective way to learn and something
it's something that gets remembered
we're taking doing exam questions that I
might make up sort of Massey questions I
don't know if that's remembered ten
years later but I think people projects
are along with this new approach comes a
new paradigm for measuring student
learning projects involve more than
right and wrong answers projects are
subjective and bringing the subjectivity
into a math course comes with some
initial skepticism especially from
students who are so used to the typical
learn the subject perform on the test
way of doing things one of the things
that makes professor Strang in his
courses so special is that he's not
attached to these paradigms in 1806 five
in one of the videos you talk about
grading students work and you tell them
that although this is important to
create their work it's not your main
concern that your main concern is
actually learning with them right
could you yeah that's right so typically
the first few days of class these guys
as you know what's the class average
gonna be how are we gonna be graded I
don't have any answers for that stuff
so I say what is totally true that I'm
not I don't feel my main job is to grade
them my job is to teach them or learn
with them and that's what I continue to
do and gradually they begin to believe
you know at the beginning it's they
still think okay but he's got to give me
a B or C or an A no but really that's
not what 1806 5 is about a grade it's
just not math is a something you do you
don't just read you have to do it you
have to think about it
the way to learn math is they get into
it and work on a thing which takes some
thought it's not you don't say it
immediately but you see it eventually
one of my favorite takeaways from
Professor Strang's approach is that he
centers his lessons around the humans in
his class for him it's about engaging
with the students in his course as
people and the learning is done by
everyone well first I'd like students
and I want to help and maybe the key
point is to think with them not to just
say ok here it is listen listen up I
think through that the question all over
again
as they do but and it and you have to
give time you can't zip through a proof
because this class has to be sort of
thinking with you and it happens that I
lose the thread or I come up to a dead
end
where I don't know what I'm supposed to
do next but well that's ok because
students are gonna hit dead end so it's
seems to me it's ok for me to get stuck
too and then even they see oh ok maybe
this this is the way to get out of that
corner
I suppose I try to think it through once
again and that then you sort of
automatically see the word you we
recognize what words you need to use and
what step what the steps are yeah if you
if you don't know if you're not thinking
of yourself then you're probably going
too fast
and not connecting with the thinking of
the class and of course you don't know
what everybody is thinking in that class
but overall if if you say sort of
conscious of the class conscious of
where they are that's I think the same
for any speaker is to be conscious of
the audience units it may be the key
point is to make it human you know your
your your a person like for this do
a person the book isn't quite a person
but it was written by a person and to
see that it's just like a natural thing
to do yeah so essentially I think the
thing is I like students I like math and
putting them together is just the best
job in the world professor Strang shares
additional thoughts on teaching linear
algebra and matrix methods and data
analysis signal processing and machine
learning in videos within the instructor
insight sections of his OCW courses you
can find them at ocw.mit.edu/donate
and watches lecture videos discover the
magic of his teaching for yourself we're
so happy to bring you conversations with
MIT faculty who are passionate about
impacting the world in positive ways
write to us to share your story of how
you're using OCW materials to shape your
world or those of others until next time
I'm Sarah Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare